the devotee flaps his arms and shrieks
he stamps jumps up and down and stutters
like the monkey spirit that he believes
has possessed his body
eventually he's embraced by another
disciple firmly but kindly until he
snaps back to reality
others in the crowd outside bangkara
Temple show being possessed by more
violent beasts Tigers elephants oxen the
manifestation of the beasts their
tattoos are supposed to protect them
from
they charge Ford as their Spirit Animals
try to escape
into a solid wall
it might seem like an act
but for these disciples the possession
is very real
it was conscious while I was in a chance
but I couldn't control myself so I just
let it flow through me
it's faith and I don't care what other
people think the tattoos are like a
reminder for my teachers to always do
good deeds
the Abbot who founded the temple became
famous for his skill as a tattoo artist
who was said those who'd been marked
with his ink would be safe from Attack
by wild beasts
these days the tiger tattoos are still
popular
but the aspirations of those that wear
them are slightly different
we asked the person who is going to get
tattooed about what kind of effect he or
she wants in the old days people wanted
a tattoo that made them Invincible but
these days many want a tattoo that will
bring them luck and wealth
back outside the spirits of the beasts
are taking control
[Music]
then the whole crowd seems to Surge
forward
[Music]
eventually orders restored and the
Abbott leads the crowd in prayer monks
spray the disciples with holy water
that'll rejuvenate the powers of their
ink and keep the spirits that have
possessed them at Bay at least for
another 12 months Tony Chang Al Jazeera
Nikon patom Central Thailand